So we had a guest on not only cancel on us
last minute today, but do it in the room
rudest way that we've ever experienced a hurling
abuse at producer pat.
Uh, you, maybe someday I will tell the story
about what happened today, but it is crazy.
Um, but the situation we find ourselves in
is that, um, we were planning on using that
interview today and now we don't have it and
we're not on a deadline.
So because so many people are always hoping
to call in, we are opening up the phone lines
at (617) 830-4750.
Uh, let's see what is on people's minds today.
Briefly.
Uh, let's go to mark from Newport.
Mark from Newport.
We haven't heard from for a while.
Uh, what's going on mark?
Okay.
Who?
David?
Um, so I had actually posted about this on
your sub Reddit, but I wanted to try to dig
a little deeper over the phone if possible.
So you had mentioned that as opposed to Elizabeth
Warren's wealth tax, you had preferred alterations
in the way capital gains are taxed as a means
to tax accumulated capital.
So as a financial advisor, that just seems
like an inefficient way to tax accumulated
capital, which I really want to.
So I was just curious, what am I missing?
Well, how, how would you like to tax it?
I would prefer something along the lines of
Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax, just because
there's not as many ways that people like
me are required to basically help people avoid
that tax.
If you read into her proposal, it's pretty
much just every dollar over 50 million, um,
with nothing really excluding.
Now I would be open to the conversation of
excluding certain types of assets from that
or if you're forced to draw assets, maybe
avoiding them from other types of taxation
or, I don't know, I'm open to that conversation,
but I just as I think as a means as to have
a broader tax base to bring in more revenue
and just to to limit wealth inequality.
I think there's less room for people like
me to help people avoid paying taxes.
Yeah, I mean I think that you have to balance
every single one of these proposals with the
path to making it a reality and a number of
what seemed to be like pretty good legal analyses
that I've read say that passing a wealth tax,
like what she is proposing, whether or not
you exclude certain types of assets would
be extraordinarily difficult and it could
take a decade while it's hung up in courts.
So I think there's simpler things that could
be done that would be legally less complex
in order to raise revenue.
I mean one of them is, and this is usually
thought of merely in terms of the context
of social security's viability, but you could
raise the income cap on social security from
whatever it is now, 123,000 I believe, to
something higher than that.
You don't have to put any new infrastructure
in place.
You're literally just changing the number
by a different amount than you would by inflation
alone and you immediately generate significantly
more revenue when it comes to capital gains.
You are right that there are whole industries
built around helping people avoid capital
gains, but there are also changes that can
be made at the most drastic, which would have
a lot of opposition would be taxing capital
gains at the same rate as ones a wage would
be tax based on their income.
Um, that would be really do realize the game.
I'm sorry, what was that?
Oh, I'm sorry to interrupt.
You still get to choose when you realize that
game and then you can still like Orient your
investment allocation.
You can keep the games on there.
There's no question about it.
It's not a silver bullet for sure.
Um, but I think that when we think you're
thinking about all the right stuff, I think
that the PR, what we should really think about,
even if we like the wealth tax in principle
is the reality that legislatively it would
be extremely difficult.
That's not a reason not to think about it.
It's not a reason not to do it.
I just think there may be lower hanging fruit,
but it sounds like you're thinking along the
same lines.
Yeah.
The bottom line is that is accumulating capital
needs to be taxed, so whatever can get passed
should get pass.
All right mark, great to hear from you.
Mark from Newport.
I was now down the road from you Narragansett
over the weekend.
Oh, no way.
I, I lived there while I was in school.
Yeah.
You know, I didn't love it.
I have to admit I didn't, it wasn't like the
best place, but it was a, it was a good, a
good weekend.
All right, mark, great to hear from you.
Appreciate the call.